okay let's talk about the arteries and
the veins and i'm actually going to talk
about both of them
kind of simultaneously because there's
some really interesting differences i
want to point out between the two we
know that they're both vessels but there
are some really important differences
between how they work and what they do
so this is your heart and coming off
your heart is
the aorta and before
this video i've been drawing the aorta
quite differently
kind of showing its branches and here
i'm showing it kind of stretched out and
i'll show a few of the branches but
really
the point of the drawing is not to make
it anatomically correct you can tell it
definitely is not anatomically correct
because that wouldn't make any sense at
all to have blood going off to one side
but really i want to show you a concept
in this video a few concepts concepts
actually so here we have let's say the
veins and i'm going to stretch that out
as well and let's imagine that all of
the veins are dumping into this one
final vein that gets back to the to the
heart
and so i'll draw the branches kind of
coming in
to the vein here and here
and we know that the arteries and the
veins are
trying
to get blood out to the capillaries
so let me show you what a zoomed in
version might look like of the capillary
so we've got let's say some capillaries
here
and maybe some here
and
here and you know of course in real life
you don't have three sets of capillary
beds which is what
i'm drawing here but really you have
thousands and thousands right
and let's not forget you know that these
capillaries are basically found in
different parts of the body so you might
have for example a bone and some
capillaries in the bone and you might
have the second capillary might be going
to your face
let's say even specifically your nose
and
this third capillary bed that might be
going down to your foot
so you have blood in your foot
so you have
different parts of the body all getting
capillaries and
the blood is going to start at the heart
go to the capillaries through the
arteries and then return through all of
those veins and we've kind of lumped it
together and what i want to show you now
is that this very very simply is the
systemic circulation
systemic circulation
now of course you know
that there's also the pulmonary
circulation so what does that look like
let me draw that out here pulmonary
circulation
so pulmonary you know means lungs
and i've shown you previously in another
video that there are
is blood going to these lungs
in a very low pressure system so we
talked previously about low pressure and
high pressure systems and now just
remember that this is kind of how it
gets there you have the deoxygenated
blood or the the blood and the blue
vessels kind of going up like that
and this would be the
pulmonary artery
pulmonary artery
i'll write art for artery and we have
the pulmonary vein
bringing that blood back to the heart
with oxygen in it
pulmonary vein
so that's your pulmonary circulation so
you have pulmonary circulation and you
have the systemic circulation and i'll
get back to why i drew the pulmonary
artery in blue and pulmonary vein in red
in just one second let's just put that
on the side for a moment
and let's get into exactly how to think
about arteries and veins in general so
in general
i think of arteries as taking blood away
from the heart that's probably the
easiest and most clear way of figuring
out what an artery is exactly so
arteries are taking blood away from the
heart so let me just draw a little arrow
here
and
veins are bringing blood back and so
this becomes our first point
point number one
and this is the point of difference
between the two of them is the direction
of flow and and even if you look at the
pulmonary system you can see that that
remains true that the arteries are
taking blood away and the vein is
bringing the blood back
okay point number two now you see that
the
arteries are drawn in red for the most
part and so usually arteries have
oxygenated blood that they're bringing
out to the tissues
and then the veins carry the
deoxygenated blood that they're bringing
back from the tissues so point number
two is really about the color
and so let me write that in here
so this would be like a little
red blood cell with
hemoglobin in it
and this is a little
red blood cell still called a red blood
cell even though its color is more blue
but it's still got hemoglobin in it but
the hemoglobin down here down here
actually
doesn't have any oxygen left and so the
color looks quite different so the color
of
arterial blood is usually red because of
the fact that
oxygen is bound to the hemoglobin and
less oxygen is bound on the venous side
so that's why it turns blue
now i want to just put a little star
there because that's not always true
and you can see where clearly it's not
true is over here so i've actually let
me star the pulmonary circulation where
you can see that the pulmonary artery
and vein i'll start that just to really
emphasize the point or actually the
reverse of what i just said right
because the pulmonary artery is actually
going to carry the deoxygenated blood
and the pulmonary vein is carrying the
oxygenated blood so clearly that's the
reverse of what i just said but that is
one exception to the general rule which
is that arteries definitely look red and
veins generally look blue okay so those
are two points of differences between
the arteries and veins let's keep going
so now you know
that arteries
are high pressure right because the
heart is pumping the blood out and it's
going to be under very very high
pressure and so i kind of think of the
arteries as being like a river a fast
flowing river
so you can think of this as
fast
flowing high pressure so that is the
third difference this is a high pressure
system
third difference is that it's a high
pressure system in fact maybe i'll even
emphasize the point
by writing the word very large high
pressure
and actually the other thing we think
about with arteries is that there's not
so much volume in the arteries so if you
actually looked at let's say i froze
time now as you try to figure out where
all of the blood was located
not too much of it is in the arteries so
it's actually a very low volume system
i'll write volume very small
and the veins are the opposite they're
kind of a
large volume
system
and they have really kind of low
pressures it's all right pressure very
small over here
and if you actually figured out what
percent is where in terms of the amount
of blood about five percent of the blood
at any point in time would be in the
heart
and let's say about five percent would
be in the capillaries
and then about uh
10 percent or so would be in the lungs
so what are we up to now we're at 5 and
5 is 10 10 plus 10 is 20
and then we have another about 15
percent in the arteries
so about 15 percent
so that's actually not too much blood
and so the remaining uh what is that 65
of the blood is actually
in the veins at any point in time
so that's remarkable right about
two-thirds of the blood at any point in
time is actually sitting in all the
veins combined and so the way i've drawn
it is really not really the best way to
draw it i i should really erase this
and really redraw this to make it much
more accurate it should look a lot more
like this right like a big giant lake
of blood
and so this is actually how to think
about the veins it's actually a very
very
low pressure but a high volume system so
that might be the third point i'll bring
up on the
on the blood side or on the vein side is
that it's a high volume system so high
volume
now we've talked about
the direction of flow we talked about
the fact that one side carries more
oxygen than the other and we've also
talked about the fact that the arteries
are a high pressure low volume system
and the veins are a high volume low
pressure system so what are some other
differences so one other difference is
that
in the arteries you actually don't have
any valves now
i don't know how to label that to make
it super clear but let me just find some
sort of open spot here and write number
four there are no valves in that
arterial system
whereas on the venous side you actually
do have valves you have these valves
that come together actually make it and
make it very clear by making the two
sides touch
and the blood kind of goes through like
that so you have these valves that keep
the blood going in the right direction
so that would be the fourth
point
of difference between the two so you
have these valves and you might get
confused because you think well doesn't
the heart also have valves and it does
the heart also has valves but the veins
have a different type of valve and
that's actually to keep the blood
flowing in the right direction you can
imagine that you probably don't even
need that in the arterial side because
the pressures are so high that the for
the blood is forced to go one way
whereas in the
veins because it's kind of like a giant
lake
water can kind of swirl around and
around and around and so it's helpful to
have valves keeping it going in the
right direction so that's the fourth
point of difference
so now think about the fact that you
might have a break in the arterial
system so let's say that you have uh
an accident and you cut an artery or a
big artery let's say what would it look
like so if you have a break right here
you would actually have like a fountain
of blood
coming out right there because it's
under such high pressure that it's just
going to spew out right
and so this is basically what it looks
like when you actually cut an artery
again because of the fact that it's
under such high pressure and now on the
venous side on the vein side if you have
a break it looks really different
because if you have let's say a break
right here you'd actually get kind of a
pool of blood just locally
before it clots off because again you
have
very low pressure so it's just going to
kind of quietly pool
and
you might get a bruise right there but
it certainly won't look like a fountain
of blood and so that's actually another
final point of difference which really
gets back to the high pressure system on
the arterial side and the
high volume low pressure system on the
venous side